حلقات جديده من وثائقي هاري وماجين طرحت
اليوم على منصه نتفليكس وربما يرافقها
الجدل كما حدث سابقا الحلقات الثلاثه
الاخيره بامكان المشتركين على المنصه
متابعتها مع توقع المزيد من الانتقادات
للعائله الملكيه البريطانيه من او في
المجموعه الاولى من الحلقات التي صدرت
الاسبوع الماضي شلنهاري وماجن هجمه شرسه
على وسائل الاعلام بسبب معاملتهما لهما
بانها وقال انها عنصريه الا ان افراد
العائله الملكيه انفسهم نجوا نسبيا من
الانتقادات في تلك الحلقات لكن من المتوقع
ان تكون الانتقادات اكثر حده في الحلقات
الجديده عندما اشار هاري الى وجود تحايل
مؤسسي وقوله ان اشخاصا لم يتوقفوا عن
الكذب لحمايه اخيه الامير ويليام ولي
العهد الحالي المقطع الترويجي للحلقات
الجديده
مقتطفات عن محاميه ماجن وصديقه لها تحدثتا
فيه عن قيام قصر باكينغام باطلاع السحافه
على قصص سلبيه عن الزوجين لتجنب نشر القصص
غير المرغوب فيها عن افراد العائله الملكه
للاخرين محاميه ماغين اعتبرت انه كانت
توجد حرب حقيقيه ضد ماجد فيما وصفت
الصحافه بحسب الوثائق بانها كانت حربا من
الزوجين على العائله الملكه هاري تسال في
جزء من هذا الوثائق عندما او عن ما يحدث
له ولزوجته ان لم يغادرها بريطانيا ووصف
الخروج بانه رحله نحو الحريه
قصه هالو ماكنه بعض الاستحسان في الولايات
المتحده
لعملها في المجالات الخيريه وحقوق الانسان
بينما اتهمتها وسائل الاعلام بريطانيه
بالسعي الى جني الملايين من مكانتهما
الملكيه عبر التهجم على العائله صحف
بريطانيه نقلت عن مساعدين ومستشارين
سابقين لافراد من العائله الملكيه رفدهم
لروايه الزوجين بينما قال قصر الباكينغهام
ومكتب الامير ويليام في قصر
كاستنجتون انهما لم يعلق على الحلقات
الوثائقيه لكن بعض المواطنين البريطانيين
والسياح الاجانب علقوا على السلسله نتابع
بعض الارق
ايه وينك
ماي بلاي بويكا